public services play a role in many
aspects of our lives for example in
education or to help people find jobs
there are also important partners of the
business community but too much red tape
lack of transparency or slow services
can be major problems for citizens job
seekers and entrepreneurs that's why the
European Social Fund is being used to
modernize and streamline public
administrations projects trained civil
servants in management skills and better
delivery of services they also help
boost online government services which
facilitate and speed up administrative
procedures
more efficient public services mean
people can start up and run businesses
more easily and create more and better
jobs the ESF is also used to improve
other local social services ranging from
setting up more child care facilities to
modernizing health care
at the same time the ESF contributes to
a better developed civil society local
charities NGOs and social partners can
build up their capacity to fully
participate in local initiatives for
growth and jobs ultimately modern public
services are essential for helping
business prosper and boosting employment
the European Social Fund investing in
people
you